ich tue was ich tue wegen meines vaters
er gab sein leben für die suche nach
neuem wissen
wenn er oben wird unsere geschichte
erzählt der film von dem ich diese woche
eindringlich waren will im vollen
bewusstsein dass dann viele reingehen
werden und von mir aus heißt ad astra
ist von james gray und ist einzig gute
daran ist brad pitt also brad pitt
spielt den astronauten piloten
befehlsempfänger roboter was auch immer
das sein soll also eine ganz arme sau
und der film beginnt auf einem turm der
bisschen den himmel gebaut ist ganz
schön erzählt so am anfang technisch
ganz interessant das ganze gibt es aber
kürzer und besser in einem buch von neal
stephenson hat was für ein konter das
ist praktisch dieselbe geschichte gibt
es schon seit 2013 vielleicht haben sie
es geklaut vielleicht nicht ist eher
wurscht aber dafür der gute teil von
filmen auf in dem moment war von diesem
turm runterfällt der brad pitt und dann
wird es eine lange reise
und zwar eine reise zu ihm hier das ist
der planet neptun den man leicht
erkennen wird anhand dieser
besonderheiten seiner oberfläche von
nasa fotos
[Musik]
brad pitt ist dahin unterwegs und zwar
um seinen vater tommy lee jones zu
suchen denn dafür gibt man ja gerne mal
ein paar milliarden aus als nasa weil
der vater macht irgendwelche bösen dinge
und glaubt er könne mit außerirdischen
reden dies dann aber vielleicht gar
nicht gibt usw
es ist so eine geschichte die man
eigentlich erzählen muss in dem man
hinter jedem satz so weinerlich das wort
papa oder date hängt er behält er gab
sein leben für die suche nach neuen
wissen es ist ein film über ein vater
und sohn
und es handelt davon dass dreht sucht
und vielleicht findet gerät auch aber es
ist sehr nett wenn brad findet das hier
könnte sie jetzt vielleicht schockieren
ihr vater hat mit streng geheime
material experimentiert dass unser
gesamtes sonnensystem gefährden könnte
was ist daran so ganz besonders schlecht
erste mal dass es keinen sinn ergibt
jede menge schauwerte einzubauen wie
eine autoverfolgungsjagd auf dem mond
oder irgendwelche verrückten affen auf
einer weltraumstation die leute fressen
und so wenn man eigentlich gar nicht
unterhalten will sondern so ein therapie
film machen will wo jemand sozusagen auf
der suche nach seinen wurzeln ist um am
ende zu liv tyler zurückzukehren die die
ganze zeit auf ihn wartet weil die moral
nämlich sein soll wir brauchen die
anderen menschen die um uns herum sind
weswegen wir von denen sonst auch nichts
erfahren also lief taylors hauptsächlich
tätigkeit ist sie wartet auf dreht brett
sucht detlef wartet auf preetz ich mache
mir sorgen um dich ich liebe dich
das ist die komplette geschichte hätte
es auch als roadmovie machen können es
gibt keinen grund warum fucking tommy
lee jones den neptun umkreis bis brad
endlich kommt weil man hätte ja auch
einfach an der andere küste der usa
schicken können als irgendwie weiß ich
nicht halb obdachlosen und dann fährt
eben halt mit einer rostigen karen daher
und gut ist weil der ganze weg dahin ist
gesäumt von irgendwelchen schau stoßen
die sicherlich viel geld gekostet haben
die aber halt aussehen wie nasa oder
eser rekrutierungs video diese funktion
vielleicht auch erfüllen wenn man das
nicht zwei stunden angucken muss sondern
so knackig fünf minuten würde man sagen
ja ich will auch astronaut werden
aber da man ist solange angucken muss
und am ende eben nichts weiter dabei
rauskommt als was auch bei einer
familienaufstellung rauskommt oder bei
einer hypnose oder wenn du die falschen
oder richtigen tabletten nimmst ich
verstehe es wirklich nicht was das soll
ich weiß nicht wie man das zwei stunden
angucken soll die selbstfindung einer
person in der innen drin einfach nichts
ist nichts heißt noch weniger als im
weltraum und da ist das sogenannte
vakuum
beginnen sie mit dieser psychologischen
beurteilung wir schreiben sie ihren
aktuellen mentalen und emotionalen
zustand
ich fühl dich gut bereit meinen job so
gut zu machen wie ich kann
irgendwie ist das ja auch sozialkritisch
wahrscheinlich gemeint also das
sozusagen diese entfremdung vom sohn
seinem vater gegenüber irgendwas mit der
gesellschaft zu tun hat in der wir leben
okay das heißt auf dem mond gibt es auch
dhl auf dem mond gibt es auch ein apple
bis restaurant also wahrscheinlich ist
dass diese böse gesellschaft in der wir
alle waren werden und fetisch werden und
die beziehung vergänglich sind und es
nur noch um geld und kommerz und so was
alles geht
warum kann er das nicht in der mall
machen weil auf seinem mond ist es da
noch so die besondere schwerkraft die
auf dem mond da herrscht nämlich eine
niedrige die sieht man in dieser
autoscooter jagd aber da wo die leute
irgendwie wohnen in dieser raumstation
da ist halt die normale schwerkraft
warum egal
das kann man sagen das ist für siegsdorf
ja gut nur wenn ich sag es ist ein film
über diesen stoff und an diesem stoff
mache ich meinen moralischen themen da
und meine psychologische katastrophe
dann muss ich mich für diesen stoff
interessieren wer sich so wenig für
diese ganzen geschichten interessiert
wie offensichtlich dieser regisseur
warum erzählt er die geschichte nicht
anders ich weiß es nicht und ich will es
auch nicht mehr wissen wo ich habe es
zwei stunden abgelöst und es reicht mir
das ist verrückt da draußen überall
brendel und flugzeugabstürze
sie nennen es die welle ich meine der
witz ist ja dieser filme das wäre ein
weiterer punkt an dem ich nicht leiden
kann ist ja erst mal von außen parallel
gebaut anderen filmen die sehr gut
funktionieren zum beispiel untersteller
ist ein vergleich der abend durch sofort
einfällt wenn man sagt okay
sogar viele der einzelnen figuren gibt
es in ähnlicher form untersteller auch
du hast den astronauten der irgendwie
seine familiengeschichte damit verbindet
dass er ganz weit raus fliegt das ist
ohnehin inters teller ist setzt brad
pitt du hast jessica chastain die zu
hause bleibt das ist in dem fünfteiler
du hast den älteren erfahreneren
menschen auf die mission schickt das ist
in der steller michael caine das ist
hier donald sutherland
also mir fällt gerade auf vielleicht ist
es einfach auch untersteller für idioten
oder so vielleicht ist es so entstanden
das konzept nur der unterschied ist da
auch wieder genau der die jessica
chastain die zu hause bleibt knackt
irgendwann ein physikalisches rätsel
weil die puzzleteile bei ihr irgendwie
ankommen das heißt sie hat eine aktive
rolle sie hat eine geschichte sie hat
eine funktion die es plastisch ist die
figur hier liv tyler ja die guckt halt
immer so menschen komplett zurück hat
brad bald gefunden darf ich mich bald
freuen
die michael caine figur donald
sutherland bei michael caine ist es so
ich bereue teil an diesem technischen
fortschritt genommen zu haben der sich
nicht überlegt hat was mit der erde
passiert wir müssen das korrigieren
glaube aber leider ist eine ganze moral
dahinter da ist eine story dahinter dass
eine figur dahinter hier donald
sutherland hat die funktion ich bin alt
ich kannte dein vater hier hast du das
geheimnis auf einem datenträger
verschwinden wird eingeführt wird
weggeschoben das ist kasperletheater die
leute werden die kulissen hin und her
geschoben und ich weiß nicht ob ich
schon erwähnt aber ich finde für mich so
gut
wir haben einen auftrag auszuführen bist
du bereit ich bin bereit
[Musik]